calcula la profundidad en centímetros de
la nieve que se acumula en un patio
durante las primeras horas de una nevada
usando la ecuación de igual a 5h que es
la profundidad de la nieve en
centímetros y h es el tiempo en horas
cuántas horas son necesarias para que se
acumule un centímetro de nieve en el
patio pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrar la respuesta queremos conocer
qué valor de h nos da un valor de d
igual a un centímetro recuerden que d se
mide en centímetros por lo que la
ecuación queda de igual a 1 y es igual a
5 por h
para despejar h dividimos ambos lados
entre 5 se cancela el coeficiente de h y
nos queda que h es igual a 1 entre 5 las
unidades de h son horas así que nos
quedan 1 entre 5 horas escribimos la
respuesta si la respuesta la pidieran en
minutos recuerden que una quinta parte
de una hora es 60 minutos entre 5 lo que
nos da 12 minutos
centímetros de nieve se acumulan en una
hora pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrar la respuesta una forma de
pensar en esto es preguntarnos cuál es
el valor de d cuando h es igual a 1 d es
igual a 5 por 1 lo que nos da 5
centímetros escribimos la respuesta
veamos otro ejercicio en una panadería
calcular el precio de para pe pastelitos
usando la ecuación de igual a 2 p qué
significa el 2 en esta situación y
tenemos que elegir una respuesta de
estas opciones pausa en el vídeo y
traten de responder a esta pregunta
recuerden que son pesos por pp
pastelitos una forma de pensar en esto
es ver qué pasa si dividimos ambos lados
de la ecuación entre p nos queda de
entre pp es igual a 2 cuales son las
unidades aquí tenemos de pesos entre p
pastelitos así que las unidades son
pesos por pastelito esta es la
proporción de unidades por pastelito
cuál de estas opciones coincide con esto
la opción a dice
la panadería vende cada pastelito en dos
pesos así es la panadería vende cada
pastelito en dos pesos esta es la opción
correcta veamos la opción ve la
panadería vende dos pastelitos por un
peso esto no es correcto la proporción
que encontramos son dos pesos por
pastelito no dos pastelitos por peso
veamos la opción se la panadería vende
dos tipos de pastelitos en el enunciado
no mencionan nada de dos tipos de
pastelitos y encontramos que venden en
dos pesos cada pastelito nos vemos en
otro vídeo